um outside of gunana who's another
artist that you would love to do like a
full body of work with cuz that's in
again I feel like yeah I was just
telling Ace that about cord I'm like bro
like back in the day like it used to be
one producer right you know what I'm
saying and that was like the nas days
and the '90s and all that like it was
well well not n he was it it felt very
curated it felt very like even if you're
not getting every like like you know it
felt like the albums were moving in
sonically cuz it was one sound yeah
exactly so like it it we got to get back
to that to that point I would love to do
that with a lot of different people um I
work a lot a lot with with Rody and I'm
doing like his next project right now oh
really yeah how's it sounding cuz we're
waiting incredible R's an alien people
people don't understand R is a [__]
alien yeah yeah yeah he he different and
it sucks because like I feel like please
excuse me for being antisocial came out
in December of
2019 and then the pandemic hits the box
is the biggest song in the [__] world
and like he really really wasn't able to
like fully enjoy what that's like with
the world open like for real like I mean
obviously he went on his tour right
before the pandemic started yeah but
like Festival season was out for him y
you know what I'm saying that whole
and you know he is for he's a literal
antisocial guy like he's an introvert
like people think it's like a gimmick or
something it's not no we like one and
the same we talk He he'll be telling me
stuff I'm like bro I I do the exact same
thing but he's an alien like he's so
good like yeah he's fire so so you're
handling a lot of his new project yeah
yeah yeah I'm I'm helping him pick out
all the songs and like do the track
listing so that's somebody I'm that's
like a good friend of mine you know what
I mean we've been locked in for some
years just on some some brother [__]
just having conversations not even about
music
so with this it's like I really want him
to win yeah me too man he's a great kid
yeah for sure that'll be hard um for you
man uh I always say there's a few ways
to go about the pub game right because
it is a very
interesting side of the game if you're
an upand cominging producer sometimes
taking a pub deal too like too early
could [__] you up but sometimes taking
it too soon can also help you out cuz
they put you in a bunch of sessions and
[__] that might not happen for you like
what would be the advice you would give
in terms of how to navigate the pub
world as a producer or a songwriter I
man I still got notes about the
difference between um C- publishing and
admin inside my phone to this day yeah
from just reading articles and teaching
myself on what's the difference and
being able to make a calculator decision
I didn't take a co- deal until like two
years of success you because for who
don't know like an admin deal is very
bare minimum they're handling kind of
they're administrating it yeah they're
they're they're handling kind of the
gruntwork of your Pub yeah a c-pub deal
they're fully Partners on your
publishing for either for perpetuity
which you shouldn't sign never uh or
like a 10-year period or whatever the
period is 10 years is too long but
whatever it is yeah um so yeah so there
are differences for that but like for
you like what what what made it make
sense for you to do a c-b situation
eventually the the the money you know
what I mean and where I was at in my
life and in my career I had already did
uh uh uh admin deal and was making money
and it was cool and I was able to live
but it was my situation you know what I
mean and when the opportunity came it's
like all right cool we going to take
this you know what I mean and from that
I was able to pay my grandmother's house
off take care of my mom take care of
myself you know all of these different
things that I that I always dreamt to do
the opportunity came and I did it so I
say for anybody like the young guys the
older guys whatever it is it's like you
got to
really understand what these things are
first and then make a calculated
decision don't CU there's not a one shoe
fits-all situation for everybody every
Everything could be different for
everybody like different situations
might work for you wherever you're at in
life or your career vice versa something
yeah so I always say like just educate
yourself like the more you know about it
the easier to be able to make a decision
when somebody does come cuz they always
come you get a big song you getting call
from everybody you know what I mean and
it's it's whatever it's going to be
whoever you comfortable with but you got
to know what you're doing it's it's
gonna happen if you catch one it's
everybody happen yeah and you gota you
got to know what you're doing so